let's go back to our top story those
airstrikes and serious Rebel House city
of Italy which have killed at least 11
civilians we're going to talk to
an activist in north adelib thank you
very much indeed for being with us can
you tell us what's been happening
thank you very much in fact yesterday
all of us we saw that Russian warplanes
were targeting the Russian M4 why today
we see them targeting very far from
their pound from their limits in fact
they are targeting the Syrian M4 The
Villages and towns which are full of
civilians the civilians who were
displaced from their own own towns and
and and Villages by Russians in fact
today the airstrikes the Russian
airstrikes killed more than 11 people
enduring more than 30 people in many
villages like this is
the main market after they targeted in
fact the main Market in this assure and
another also many air strikes on the
Western countries
and even in italicity this is in
addition of course to other and the
artillery selling these attacks in fact
are shocking the syrians who are living
in Northwest Syria exactly after we
heard yesterday okay what was happening
in Russia we couldn't we even didn't
imagine that they will uh might emplify
their anger from what's going on in
Syria on sorry in Russia on syrians so
in fact what happened today it was a
kind um reminder for syrians that we are
still here we are still here to kill
more more civilians and more people one
thing I want to be clear about I I need
to ask you how can you be confident that
these were Russian aircraft
in fact in general here I mean there are
many people in fact who like
places which follow the plane uh
movements and all these were these
things came from airport
basement in in Latakia so that's why we
we can make sure of the of all movements
of the warplanes that attack people in
that area so that's how how we can know
and we are sure aware of that yeah talk
to us about the the situation that the
people there are facing because you said
that there have been artillery strikes
here you said there have been air
strikes the world has largely taken its
eye away from Syria talk to us about
what life is like for people there
unfortunately in fact in a time where
syrians are suffering from all
conditions exactly after the devastating
earthquake that happened just about
three or four months ago these people in
general the the
humanitarian situation is devastated in
North Syria people are suffering to even
have their their their their their to
make their life uh if while they are
worried and in fact very
stressed about the many movement of the
Civil regime and Russian
forces on the on the in the in the front
lines in fact the last few days we
witnessed a lot of movements on the
south and four roads by the Russian and
and the serial reaching forces which
make people in all notes idlibs are very
worried in fact we also are hearing many
like threats by Syrian regime voices
about
we appreciate it thank you very much
indeed for being with us on Al Jazeera